through that PO Malignaggi here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Paul I'm
Goodrich my pleasure to be on right
thanks for joining
so how has MacGregor looked to you oh
you know you getting ready it's a big
progress a little by little you can
definitely his conditioning is getting
up there and he ended in better shape of
my first box couple weeks ago then I had
to leave last week how to go work of a
broadcast for Showtime and I returned on
Monday this week and we booked to around
last night so what I've been able to do
to around and this conditioning is good
enough to do to around you know I'm
ready of from one one press United
States progress so when you say progress
I mean do you think he's got a shot here
Paul listen I mean to say he's going to
win the fight is a bit far-fetched all
but I'll say this
you know it's what I've been saying it's
you know he's getting himself in good
shape and he's putting himself in the in
positions where he knows how to be
dangerous now if one of those situations
presents themselves in a fight need able
to land a big shot or or gets with
attention with a big shot you know
sometimes it's a small moment you're
looking for but sometimes a small moment
can become your big moment and sometimes
that big moment can on the fight from
the outside looking in looking at it as
a whole yes you favor forward me whether
it is a slim able domain you favor
Mayweather but then you take little tip
is like that a board moment can turn
into something bigger and you realize
we're kind of can or maybe has a change
to do something like I said I myself
woman I'm in Campbell Conor I will tell
you
Troy was his favorite you know I
understand a boxer
I understand what is the legitimate
favor but here's the guy who's in Conor
McGregor was proven a lot of that was
wrong in the past and he's got all that
self belief in the world and talking to
him and training with him you know he
believes he believes he can do this he
can do this as well out some people
might call securities in to put my call
it ignorance you might call it supreme
confidence whatever it is I mean all
this is we're going to see English well
I mean look he's got to say that anyway
right Paul I mean he's got to believe it
does why do I have to say he does have
to say it but is one thing about just
saying or Nothing believing it really
you know didn't his honor million
dollars for him you know he could show
up just let me check you know you
doesn't have to work as hard as you
working in camp you know you work hard
you know
what a guy who doesn't believe he's
gonna win which I was working the way
he's playing it in he may still lose the
fight don't get me wrong but what I'm
saying is you know he's going into it
totally believe you can pull this off
you know because if he didn't there's no
way you would put in this kind of work
ethic into the training camp you know
with 12-round when I told on the
sparring he still I want out he's
already did enough people around and I'm
sure we'll continue reduce his farm in
the future
Paulie Malignaggi joining me here in the
Rich Eisen show what about the reports
that he's been knocked out while
sparring Paul that was all obvious stuff
you know I think when they started the
report first came out he was just
returning from the press tour in Europe
the person I was saying Jesse lagers I
was saying that he saw Connor get
knocked out it was physically impossible
to do that because Connor arrived in Las
Vegas that Saturday right after the
press tour he left I think it's two
three three weeks ago he arrived
Saturday in was day is it Sunday the
interview came out from that's bogus
saying that he's still counting on Tulsa
to it's a physical impossibility almost
Congress fine 14 hours and inspiring the
same day honor they were just supposed
to be in the gym but also another thing
is you know we trained to deal with
headquarters you know it's gated off and
know we can come in it's very private so
you're not going to get anybody out
there it's going to long legions and
what about the comment you made recently
Paul that McGregor's power you wouldn't
call it oh my god power but it's
definitely above average can you put a
few more pieces of meat on those bones
there oh yeah what are the theories I
mean most people in life don't have oh
my god pal I mean every grown man wants
to believe you can punch most men can
punch I'll tell you that right now and
then and then the ones I can't punch the
oh my god powers you more rare you know
you know like I probably count on
maybe both hands on the fingers of both
my hands how many times I've been in a
room with people oh my god tell those
inspiring insights you know it's very
rare and I've done thousands thousands
of rounds in the gym you know in fights
oh yeah oh my god power so rare that you
will never see it but it doesn't mean a
guy can't punch you know Connor can get
your attention Connor if you can treat
you with a clean shot you know get you
attention me rock you me and drop you
you know I'm saying but but it's not
where you know there's get
is been guys up in the ring with where
they hit me and I literally she was on
top of my head all the way to the end of
my toes you know and it's like me was
this guy guy you know it's not that kind
of power but it's also no power to where
if I feel it I'm gonna say hey man you
know what hit me again because if I
don't feel it it's definitely not that
not not weak either you know only I
think it can hurt you you can get your
attention and he definitely can't finish
a fight with that kind of power so then
as you've been sparring with them Paul
Malignaggi here in the Rich Eisen show
what attributes of Floyd's were you
trying to mirror mimic provide for Conor
to prep him for what Floyd might do well
I think for the most part they brought
me in for my speed my hand speed and
just my flexibility of Savannah slider
always was there in my career and
Floyd's kind of athletics key china
fighter a time a timing kind of fighter
you know as my timing is better and
better I think uh Connolly worker will
get to work on some of that like last
night I was able to you know get in a
lot of more counters and I was the first
time against them you know uh so my
timings coming to play again that I I
myself had not been training better
tired back to March you know so we get
in better shape a little by little so I
think I'll brought him mainly to the
timing and the speed any athleticism
so you didn't throw stacks of hundred
dollar bills at him is what you're
saying yeah not a ton of that well I
mean in terms of that though I mean
Floyd's going to try and get in Connors
kitchen mentally verbally absolutely how
do you think Connors prepared for that
because he obviously got some quality
game on that front but uh this can also
get Connor out of his skull in a way
that well not all suit him well I think
that's rich Central Park the reason why
they brought me and last night I
literally talk to old school grounds I
don't think I shut up what programs and
also so I think part of the are you
saying
give me give me some ideas were you
saying I think I don't know it's
radio-friendly rich well I mean can you
can you can you tone it down a little
bit I know boom I was basically saying
like you know I was hanging it under his
skin saying they told me you can find
you why my punching harder than you you
know or or you know I would body shots
on and say like that that feels right
they don't give you much lower than I'm
a you know like oh you like those body
shots right or they don't they don't
take loretta something that you know
because you know body shop
numel fatigue you tend to see more body
shots and boxing when you do mixed
martial arts you know and so you know it
just just roundabouts tough to cut again
in his head you know and I think it's
also part of the preparation for for
Floyd who I think will also do a lot of
talking as well as usually does when
it's all said and done poly tape the the
the one thing that I'm just I'm having
at rough tough time even getting past
and you mentioned that you sparred with
him for 12 rounds which is great but
that said I mean when you're when you're
in the spotlight in the glare and you
got Floyd Mayweather doing the throwing
and the punching and any cat mouse this
is just not even close to anything that
Conor has come to in terms of endurance
in terms of how long something can last
how can you possibly get ready for
something like that even with training
only the thing I mean Conor has a guy
that especially the first time you see
him you're probably going to get weird
angles and weird weird shots oh you
haven't seen before like the first time
I possibly should go
it took me a few rounds to really get
settled in and be like you know what is
this guy doing you know me to the first
you'll see and when you'll think you
don't even they gotta they know he's
doing you know but then you start to
realize you know how to make it work for
him so then you have to kind of adapt to
it start a good time you know they don't
and so on and so forth soaps you know I
believe early on in that fight um miss
Connors best opportunity not so much
them as much as people think what he
just got a rush I don't think it's so
much that he has a rifle but I just
think Connors just unorthodox style will
take a few rounds to kind of adjust as
what Mayweather and and those rounds are
fully shinola just means windows out
adjust without getting reckless so he's
not use any records but while he's
trying to adjust me we kind of have on
the back foot a little bit and apply
some pressure and apply some some of the
stuff you want to do and also I don't
think he's just down to the early part
of the fight I think late in the fight
if Connor is able to land VC shot during
fight he's able to have some of those
moments that I spoke about earlier here
and there and here and there maybe late
in the fight you know four-year-old
Mayweather is a little bit tired a
little bit fatigued it's all big maybes
but it's late in the fight maybe was
tired of fatigue then the younger
fresher Conor McGregor can try to you
know put some hard on him late in the
fight as well again these all big navies
are all big IFS but they're all aw
they'll definitely have to be spoken
about they're all possibilities yeah I
mean we had Dominick Cruz here last week
he thought that if we didn't get it done
the first six rounds though that that
would be the problem that he's got to
get he's got to get Floyd in the first
six rounds in the cottage I don't think
is that black and white because even if
you don't feel and guess without of
their in the first rounds but what have
you done enough damage to Floyd you know
first advance to where now you've been
slowing down for 10 11 12
you know and again okay like I said
before these a big IFS a big maybe but
that's why I don't necessarily say it's
not just it's not that like I want to do
the right gray area and there's locust
such as the first expansion how will
firstly found it played out as well are
you making a champion mayweather are you
making me whether expanding of energy or
are you taking enough gasoline out of
the tanks of Mayweather you know or even
if you don't get him out of there you
know there's other little subtleties you
have to look for oh they were in those
first five six rounds if kind of doesn't
get him out that maybe you can play
along completely Savannah later in the
cycle again they want is 40 they one of
them fall in two years know that it's
not some you have to put some of that
into consideration so you are you're in
the rotation of spark how many how many
are there all because a handful of guys
you know I'm totally the biggest names
sparring partner here you know the new
you have like one of the military have a
fine amateurs frightening the children
brandings from Ireland use of the high
level amateur fighter is like Shawn
Johnson who's been out in boxes done
some boxing and mixed martial arts you
know he's a little bit of a journeyman
but that's not been with the best of the
best fighters you know and then there's
another mixed martial artist a couple
mixed martial artists sometimes he
throws in on the end of sparring one guy
named Franz and one guy named up Artemis
you know usually use a demo out you know
you can just kind of fill up around it
if he doesn't get enough rounds from the
boxers flesh I was just being in 12
hours
when's the next time you your scheduled
spar with Conor oh I don't know it's not
like it's not I couldn't drive he's kind
of weird like that I just gave you don't
even what you know really until like
maybe a day before come on well so you
want views what are you okay what did
you texture do you get a 10 song no his
team will let us know you know there's
where smarm partners weren't a separate
house they don't stuff so you know where
we'll get to notice you know he started
every two days early scheduling leaders
BBQ teas okay
but we'll see we'll see one on the next
time use
okay all right Paulie thanks for thanks
for joining let's get you back on before
the fight okay yes sir it's definitely
and as far as earnest these predictions
I'm a Giants fan let's go Giants
and I'll say what's up to Gerry for our
another book one finalist okay very good
Brooklyn in the house you take care of
Paulie you got it
Paulie Malignaggi so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches